[Music]
mike
is in orange county hey mike welcome to
the dave ramsey show
good afternoon dave it's a pleasure to
speak to you both you too what's up
um okay so i'm sort of in a semi
malformed baby step
3b and i'd love to get your advice at
the start of 2020 i decided to purchase
my very first home
i was previously trying really hard to
save up to 20 but i felt like with
interest rates being really low
plus with the southern california real
real estate market appreciation
every year that i was sort of delaying
was putting me further and further
behind
um so i took a 15 000
loan from my 401k in order to help boost
the down payment
but the intention there was to rent out
the extra room to a friend
where the net profit after a year was
going to be fifteen thousand dollars so
i could completely pay off the loan in a
single year
um the experiment went well my friend is
interested in staying for another year
so
my question to you is should i take the
cash now
and pay back the 401k loan or since the
401k loan interest is being paid back to
me
and he's going to stay for another year
should i take the 15 000
and put it towards the equity in the
home so that the next time i refinance
or re-amateurize i'm closer if not
beyond 20
and can drop pmi yeah well that would
depend on whether you're going to follow
our plan or yours
right i i've been an
advocate follower of your plan i think
this is the one point that i deviated
and then you're wanting to deviate more
yeah
why would you say more well i would
never tell you to borrow on your 401k to
break pay down your home so that you
could get rid of pmi
yeah i i wasn't going to borrow more
no effectively by not paying off the
loan with the money and putting it on
the house it's the same thing
yeah oh i see okay
so pay off the loan yeah pay after them
okay and then work to pay down your
principal and then
you'll have to get an appraisal and
reset and get your
um get your stuff get your
pmi going that way later i have done
lots of stupid things that worked
and the only downside of that is is it
made me think it worked yes
an example is uh we were
22 years old or 23 years old and we went
on our very first cruise
right we had never seen anything like
that that was luxury we
were country people from tennessee we
got on that boat and they were like
you know they were had swordfish and
they had all this stuff and
i mean the place was like a palace yeah
yeah
and my wife bless her heart
what what happened walks by
this evil thing called a slot machine
i'm just gonna try this i think this
would be fun
and i said what about losing money is
fun i don't understand how is it fun to
lose money
she drops a quarter in and of course you
know what happened she pulled the one
arm bandit
the stinking thing goes off like a
christmas tree man
quarters are going everywhere woman won
like three hundred dollars in quarters
you know what that cost me about three
thousand about
seven hundred we didn't have three
thousand i was twenty-two oh
she put the whole 300 back in over the
trip plus another 500 looking for
another 300.
because stupid worked once yes yes
yeah and that's the thing about doing
stupid just because it works once
doesn't mean you sign up for it again
i've done it i've done it half of my
life
me too and i'm just going look there are
just because you
you know you jumped off the building and
you didn't break your leg
because you landed in some a pile of
leaves right
doesn't mean jumping off of buildings is
smart right
but i've done it right i've done it half
my life and i just i had to quit
i had to quit i had to go okay there are
principles the law of gravity
is a principle yes borrowing money
borrowing on your 401k is never a good
idea let's
reiterate why you don't borrow on your
401k number one you unplug
a good mutual fund yes you do that would
have been making 10
12 in order to pay yourself back five or
six and somehow that seems smart i never
figured that out
i'm getting the money you're getting the
money the other way dummy yep
you know and so i don't get it the other
thing is when you leave the company and
you will leave the company when you die
you get fired or you get a better job
yes
you will be leaving this company yeah
not if
when it's a stable job yeah pandemic
breath
right i got that so yeah
when you leave your company you will
that that loan is considered an early
withdrawal and if you do not repay it in
60 days it is taxed
at your tax rate plus a 10 penalty
you're gonna get hit in the mouth with a
40
i got you told you not to do this
penalty so that 10
000 cost you maybe 16 000. yeah exactly
yeah
yeah somewhere in there and so and
you're just
asking for trouble yes now sometimes you
can ask for trouble and trouble doesn't
come
come on and man i'll tell you and the
reason i'm so passionate about this is i
can look in the mirror and go
i'm a doofus i have done almost every
one of these things yeah i never had a
401k or i would have borrowed on it
uh but you know just cause you got just
you know
the worst thing happened to me when i
was buying real estate
for nothing down the banks giving me 100
loans because i was buying it and fixing
it up the worst thing that happened to
me was
i made really good money and flipped
those houses easily on the first ten
houses yeah
so then i look up at 24 years old 25
years old
with 3 million dollars in debt
on on rental properties doing flips and
a bank gets sold to another bank and
calls our loans
the worst thing that happened to me was
the first ones worked
if i had lost my butt on the first one
the whole story would not have occurred
yes
but instead i'm like sharon this would
be fun and i put the thing in the slot
machine you know
and there you go and ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding let's do this again
robert kiyosaki must be right let's go
deeply in debt with nothing down
you know oh my god i'm going to sign up
for grant cardone i don't think so
you know no i'm not going to do that i
love robert
i love grant they're both great guys
actually and robert's a friend of mine
but philosophies
but we don't agree on those subjects as
right because i had a different
experience and a man with an experience
is not at the mercy of a man with an
opinion and i'm right there with you i
had the same experience dave
not the same but in the same area same
ideas
so this is why we're picking on you mike
because we love you man yeah we love you
and we love to pick on you
you caught into the dave ramsey show
well i mean that's it so the
the thing is just because you got i mean
what if the roommate had been the
roommate from hell and hadn't paid him
the money
we never gotten this call because he
wouldn't want to extend it
yep wouldn't want to keep doing it he'd
be like oh
i violated the principal and i got
caught and i think well if you put the
quarter in there
and call this to be fun and it just
keeps your quarter it's not fun
and i think for me dave i just i'm
scared to play with my future i'm
depending on that 401k
i'm depending on the roth ira i'm
depending on that to protect my 60 70 80
year old stuff
so i just i don't want to play with it
right now if that means i have to move a
little bit slower into
getting to where i need to get to today
so that my future has a solid future
i am okay with that you know you're
right there is a
oh
i was out at the farm with my grandson
today and
he was a little bitty guy with his daddy
and we were shooting okay the first time
the little guy shot a gun
yeah i want to teach him to be afraid uh
of guns yes they're dangerous yes
yes i don't want to teach him to be so
afraid of it that he can't shoot one
yes but i want him to have a healthy
respect
for this explosion that's going off in
your hand that's so good dave
you got to have a healthy respect and
you got to have a healthy respect for
these principles
yeah because it'll go off man yeah and
and when people don't have respect for
it that's when they get hurt come on
this is the dave ramsey show